ich fänds auch ganz nice wenn wir uns
einfach mal wenn wir mal die golden die
redstone fackeln nutzen würden
das bringt hallöchen freuen und
willkommen zur fünften folge capt auf
minecraft 3 in der letzten folge ist ein
erzähl du es einfach mal das war
letztlich folge so ich bin gerade auf
dem weg nach oben zu dir und wir sind
paar sachen mitbringen haben mir selber
ein paar sachen mitgenommen und
plötzlich so rim städte wo also konkret
auf der wurde von einem post von
atlantic art mit magie getötet nicht wir
beide nur so wird ihr für die fcz fans
ja mal im im chat zeigen ich komme
einfach hoch da seht ihr wie oft wir
gestorben sind also 20 mal und jetzt
haben wir gerade gesehen zwischen
aufnahmen gesagt kommen wir nehmen
schnell weiter auf da steht der atlantic
of the game weil wir den hier in so
einem kieshaufen eingebaut haben
beziehungsweise komme kam auf die idee
dass ihr sohn kieshaufen bauen
aber jetzt ist das ganze wasser ihre
teil umgeleitet er macht nix durst
karten knochen eingesammelt was war es
für ein knochen ganz normaler knochen
schade der hatte keine speziellen sachen
hier liegen noch ein paar items jetzt
noch mal ein schwert der jetzt quasi
zwischen den aufnahmen gestorben also
ich hoffe dass wir uns da glaubt dass
wir es gemacht haben
das ist total der ist ja nicht wirklich
gesteuerte gestorben da kommt er wieder
ich stehe ja nur er hat das spiel
verlassen es scheint ein joint game ich
glaube das ist so ein boss der kommt
immer wieder um uns zu ärgern weil ich
habe diesen vorschlag genau der stelle
wieder kommt aber es war schon sehr
krass wie es dann mit dem abgang weile
hat sich halt echt durch ganzen wende
von oben nach unten gebaut und hat auch
unsere schwerter jetzt verschlungen
werden wir keine waffen mehr
doch ich hab noch ein schwert hin weil
die spritzen ist weg wir bräuchten aber
eventuell nochmal ihm das ganze wasser
hier mal aufzuhalten hast du eine
spitzhacke leider nicht ich hab mir
gemacht aber jetzt haben wir durch den
bosc albert leider verdammt er jetzt
auch
jetzt sind dadurch zwei stürmer vor der
board sich hier noch runter sind diese
etage wohl unsere thron stehen
das wäre das echt doof ich mach mal eben
einen spritzer camp nou die knochen das
ist ein bisschen blöd jetzt ich dachte
eigentlich dass der mäher dropped desto
mehr bei rumkommt ich dachte dass wegen
diesen mega boshafter knochen noch ein
schwert brauche ich eigentlich auch ich
nehme aber jetzt einfach mal das
holzschwert mit was wir noch in der
truhe linie haben damit wir mal ein
wenig sparen
magenta haben wir aber wir brauchen
purple
aber ich glaube purple ist magento oder
ich bin mir nicht sicher was kannst du
das mal ganz kurz neben mal nachschauen
wie man paypal staind clay macht dann
schmeißt ihr mann eine spitzhacke zu da
ich du nimmst du automatisch auf dann
stellte ich mir hier einfach noch eine
kiste übrigens freuen wenn sich mal
fragen warum meinen text miteinanders
aussieht es ist ja and expect dabei
gewesen das war die skepsis drei
resource pack allerdings wurden da nur
einige dinge hinzugefügt wie
beispielsweise dieses atlantik oder so
ein paar schriftarten und so deswegen
habe ich einfach ganz viele sachen davon
im von meinem eigenen text speck
reingezogen und jetzt habe ich halt hier
dandelion mit dem zwecks texturen was
manager gemacht hat dass das ganze dann
halt ein bisschen schöner aussieht und
nicht so öle default hab ich mir gedacht
wenn ihr default sehen wollt könnt ihr
noch beim gucken der letztlich das drin
wahrscheinlich und wir werden jetzt
dieser folgenden versuchen mal wieder
eine tiefe zu machen was wir der letzten
folge uns auch vorgenommen hatten nur
dann hatten wir einen spannenden kampf
mit einem edlen team gab ja gut wir
haben noch gar keinen gar keine erden
doch leider gar keine auch kein baum
oder sonst was
also wir können aus der sternlauf blume
schon farbstoff anscheinend herstellen
und damit halten pinken wollen pinken
linksblock herstellen
pink oder war
das ist magento kennt magenta da und
hier steht purple und ich war günther
ist eigentlich bei opel steht da ja ich
hab jetzt der seite gefunden wo ich
lieber gleich purple magenta ist aber
von der farbe her wie pink acht weitere
ich schau mal nach minecraft allein eben
gerade diese bei dem texture pack bevor
sie noch also ich hab ich hab mir mal
anderes texture pack reingemacht ich so
ein ödes die fortec wenn ihr die frau
entdeckte effekt haben wollt geht zugabe
guckt sie vollkommen drin das ölleck
keinen sinn was hat es jetzt einmal geld
zu tun
kommen die über spenden appell hat die
einzelnen und es gibt auf jeden fall
magenta und purple
also sind zwei unterschiedliche sachen
und das heißt mit dem agenten müssen wir
noch abwarten wir müssen wirklich
irgendwie also babbel macht man mit nach
hause und mit lapislazuli und ich würde
einfach sagen wir wirklich noch mal im
sommer noch mal nach oben gehen
ich bin gerade hier oben und ich bin
gleich tot weil ich von einer hexe
vergiftet wurde
und hier ist jetzt eine echte hexe du
hast du vorhin gesagt so oft wunder
ja das ist doch bestimmt nur so eine
hexe dieser bossen aber jetzt steht hier
oben wirklich mal eine echte hexe
ich hab noch ein halbes herz also komme
gerne hoch ich bin auf dem weg ja ich
hab die welt ja auch gerade schon von
zombies und derweil angegriffen aber ich
bin unterwegs
wie sehr gut da ist schon wieder ein
zombie mann mann mann mann mann
die sinne auch aktiv hier die spore noch
richtig häufig schwere spinne rover
evoque design das mit der 1.8 die mobs
flüssiger sterben kann sein mir also
allgemein kam es mir halt oft auch im
vorjahr seien die 18 etwas flüssiger
läuft englisch für herforder performance
verbessern vor allem kommt mal wenn ich
jetzt zum beispiel zombie getötet der
der fliegt zu viel langsamer und viel
schöner irgendwie da
hexe tod tilgung ist auch toll aber ich
von beruf man ja wenn du hoch kommt wies
mich schon ich stehe hier in seiner
kleinen kammer das wetter bleibt ist die
nahrung wenn man genug nahrung hätte
haltung auch genug herzen und so weiter
alles offen wann kaufen
olivenöl in magenta ist endlich im sugar
sugar ich habe ca wir sind ja auch noch
die betrüger wird möge der security
leute oder was ja wenn du nichts kauft
dann kommen die an und zwingt mich dazu
hier kommen jungs hall of gaia los geht
auf ihn
doch leider an geld treppensteigen der
comic held diego comic-con lieber hier
wirklich werden ja ich muss halt eben
den bernd hier helfen ich habe mir bis
heute eine palme gekauft bei ikea habe
ich auch per hand genannt hat aber nicht
ins auto gepasst mussten wir dann
quatschen experten bisschen kaputt als
heraus dass hier oben für räume wo kommt
jetzt kommt der kollege der ist mir
nicht so vertraut der markt nicht immer
nicht so aber der ball ist ein ganz
netter klare während ich schob sich
dabei hoch zum komme nehme ich würde
schon wieder viel viel weiter oben
behalten
pass mal auf komme der bergmann gibt es
gefeiert
er kann gar nichts hier ach so jemand
kriegt so viel hunger immer durch dieses
offene flächen konnten die da oben ja da
oben sind so heftige gänge volkers hallo
als erstes nur die nötige zwischen höhle
aber da oben kommen richtig heftige
wasser tunnel und schwer
wir gehen jetzt mal machen zwar eine
treppe elektrikers ein bisschen kaputt
gemacht denkmal
euro geholt das ist doch klar
irgendeine farbe ist grün mir das ist
schön
ich hab gesagt sollten auf jeden fall
mitnehmen man wolle wenn du schon der
claim an bist jetzt ihre diese grenzen
staat muss auch mitnehmen diese roten
teile nimmt die teile auch die presse
marin kristan genau dass sie nachher
atlantis ein wenig aufpeppen können oder
schönheit genauso wie wird das mit
welcher kraft verpasst
also hier sind aber chris martin
kristalle sind ja überall press marin
kristalle und gleich sterben birne ich
sehe schon kommen gleich komplett boss
ich sehe aber ich kämpfe wir also nur
damit wir unsere sachen kommen wir sind
wir wünschen uns dann gleich wieder gar
nichts anderes mehr
guck mal hier bin ich hoch geschwommen
eben gerade okay es gibt hier vier ist
wasser tunnel keine ahnung wo sie
hinführen
aber die führenden so was haben wir hier
das ist diese checkpoints es stand
nämlich auf der website
es gibt auf der ganzen gerade solche
quartz blöcke und diese solche check
point die darstellung man sich später
hin wir hin trocken kann aber ich weiß
auch nicht genau was es damit auf sich
hat aber ich denke wir werden das regeln
können diese diese leuchten ist auch
richtig viel liebe machen am besten dann
bringe ich eben runter
du hast den atmungs händler ich habe gar
kein helm der zweck oder natur dann
unten ja dann ist ruhe
oman air gut ich komme mit dir zusammen
rutter okay so jetzt unten pass auf der
bahn der iss dich fokussiert ich find's
gut dass wir diesen das ist schon wieder
und krieger sondern blöd man dort
bettendorf mich endlich wieder ein krieg
ich habe habe ich habe keine waffe mehr
da ist
weiter ging auf sich nimmt die
kommission ich habe keine waffe mehr du
ahnst nicht wie viele ist wir sollten
hier endlich eventuell mal das
ausleuchten ort der hat eine schaufel in
der hand wieder bei mir sehen dass du
mir ein spiel weiß ich an ausnahme sehen
ich wollte mich mal nachmachen wieder da
bist du bei cap define kraft zweier
eingelenkt
lasst mich das richtig ausgeschöpft opel
wollte gm- bekomme ich hab's satt jetzt
habe ich mal das gleiche gemacht
von deiner hand hat mich auch war
künstlich aufgeregt darüber hier ja hier
darüber freue ich mich so also ob man
ihr am echten nahrungs problem ohne
scheiß ich gehe fischen ich dir und
fischen runde ehrlich ja das jetzt
können wir vielleicht mal machen würde
auch mal eingeladen an gekostet immer ja
naja kostet immer heute mit holz
sichtbaren sein obwohl wir mittlerweile
relativ viel haben auch mal sagen na ja
das kann schnell vorbei gehen
wir bräuchten auch eventuelle pilzen
kann als pilz ob machen oder eine kuh
kuvert auch mal so ich habe hier noch
die zombie brennt hier die kompakt da
mal rein
theoretisch ist schon bock wieder
erholen das mit dem nach oben zu gehen
und gewann dann brauche ich eine waffe
waffe machen
irgend jemand muss halt echt weg das ist
richtig traurig wenn man zwei möchte
eben war für manchen anderen zweite
sting zeigt dingen 1 2 so so zac und
zack dankeschön so es nicht aber das
soll noch nicht ohne es nicht schaffen
aber da man künftig das fällt mir in
diesem projekt jetzt so auf mit diesem
zombie fleisch ist das ja so krass ist
ja stanley
okay wir können wir nach oben vielleicht
hätten wir noch ein paar blöcke die wir
gebrauchen können später für die
monierten irgendwie rose wer cool und
lapislazuli wir auch gut
ich werde dir hätten wir hier versammelt
glaub ich auch so jetzt ich gehe jetzt
noch mal alle turnier ab ich bin noch
nicht bekloppt ich habe hier mal ein
amboss gesehen der gomez nicht bekloppt
eine vage behauptet ja manchmal schon
ein wenig aber ich liebe dich hier oben
nochmal um so ein bisschen gab mich
immer so in die saiten rhein wo ich als
auch das kam ja quasi gar nicht machen
weil die world poker nicht so weit
fortgeschritten ist eventuell fackeln
werden auch alternative noch die wir uns
hätten machen können
hätte hätte fahrradkette das kann nicht
mehr brauchen wir auch nicht mehr wir
brauchen unser schwert und dass ich
meine ich sitze 22 schon wieder rauschen
was auf passaus also drei also von drei
krippen habe ich zwei getötet und eines
hoch gegangen leider komme hoch nie
gesehen gehört
ja warum bist du gerade so schnell hoch
gelaufen ich dachte was geht mit ihm ab
alter stärke und annie hof hier ist
alles dunkel
ich habe mir aber gesagt wir brauchen
noch keine fackeln haben wir auch
gesehen dass wir verdammt hat wieder
irgendwie geträumt aber dass save the
world so was machen wir jetzt gehen wir
hier mal hoch was kommt ich schwimme dir
weiter her jetzt hier oben rechts nicht
irgendwas abbauen hier rein uhr gehts
weiter
conny trinke ich ertrinke wo bist du
wenn ihr über dir mal luft holen
sackgasse
ich mach' ich runterschubsen das ist
schneller geht
juli warten mutterschutz damit schneller
geht ja gar nicht im man wahrscheinlich
ich glaube deine sachen weiß ich hätte
es auch überlebt wäre ja wichtig
geschlagen hättest aber ich habe nie
wieder setzte oben machen
heute ist die konditor folge
ich habe eine idee wie das hier oben
machen freut mich für mich sehr schön
und ich bekomme luft aber einfach los wo
liegen meine ich hab dir hier oben
kommen hier oben hin
im vorhinein kleinen gang gebaut kommen
einfach hoch ja ich sehe hertha freunde
okay ich komme schon
heuer das war nicht so klug so bin ich
du kannst erst mal hier kurz ins
schwimmen dann kannst du hier space
gerät halten die da unten worden
so hätten das war meine hand so stehen
so jetzt kann ich jetzt mal ein plan
ich brauche ganz normale sachen wieder
ich meine generation gehört das sollte
dann dann stört und da ist eine
spitzhacke mehrheitswahl noch ein paar
steine hin einfach so wir brauchen einen
plan wir können uns ja einfach mal nach
oben gucken ertrinken oder erlangen kann
in der mitte damit es keiner
hier geht's auch hoch
diese haben dann führen wir nicht
sauerstoff gesorgt ich mache einfach das
wasser weg ja das geht er wunderbar ja
york
ich finds auch ganz nice wenn wir uns
einfach mal wenn wir mal die golden die
redstone fackel nutzen würden
das bringt gar nichts
und der du mir schreibt noch weiter in
die kommentare bord bleibt mal ruhig
wenn du auftaucht man stirbt dabei nicht
altherr und jetzt kommt auch noch ein
skelett
nein das meine sachen die story ist mein
re mann berüchtigt zu einer sache kommen
ja ich weiß nicht wo er gestorben ist ja
da oben bei der plattform auch hier ja
ich habe jetzt wo wir müssen aber auch
mal die folge jetzt kommen auch noch so
ricoh europe sun ich guck dir mal eben
entgegen ja du solltest mir auch viele
auch das thema was neues was geht hier
gerät ob man hier ist alles überflutet
ja stimmt müssen ist direkt also
tatsachen hier war der kopierten sachen
zack zack da geht wieder los bei
hans-dieter haase wieder viele feine im
körper stecken
1 2 3 4 5
schon bald haben erstmal entspannt ich
hab mal ein schwert von venedig hat er
zwei weil man anderes halb voll kaputt
war
freunde ich würde sagen es war wieder
eine folge wenn ich's geschafft haben
eine tipps habt et cetera schreibt ist
uns gerne in die kommentare hier machen
das ganze jetzt eben
das sieht das schon wieder bergab denn
auf mich genommen
lange hat sie ziehen sich an ein herz
wer wird eigentlich aus dem motto wie du
ja nicht die hat mindestgebot von
vanager ein alter gut ich hoffe so also
meine bilder buddies das wär's wir sehen
uns dann morgen wieder begonnen euch
gefallen derzeit sind in einer bewertung
und dann
bis morgen solle rein schöne du